uh to brenda judd right now the national
border patrol council president brendell
uh always good to have you and thanks
for joining us today let me get your
take brandon a little bit about what
casey was reporting and that is the
numbers continue to surge record numbers
at that
i guess the next question is how long
does this go on
yeah yeah now let me get to that but to
give you context um you see some florida
flags um behind me i'm in uh florida
right now with cat kamek congresswoman
kat kamik she's doing a great job to
bring attention to this issue um you
know i'm from the southwest border but
this [ __ ] clearly shows that that every
border is a border state but when you
look at those numbers when you look at
what we're dealing with right
now as the numbers continue to increase
uh we continue to get overwhelmed with
with everything that we have to do with
when we're processing um those illegal
border crosses and what that does is
that allows all of the drugs to flow
into the united states that's what's
coming up to florida that's what's going
to maine iowa um and nebraska and that's
what's killing so many of our u.s
citizens we have got to be able to get
illegal immigration under control and if
we can get that under control then we
can go after the cartels we can go after
their profits we can go after all of
those dangerous things that are coming
into the united states which includes
criminal aliens aliens from special
interest countries all of those things
that want to do harm here in the united
states but we have to have the proper
policy to do it and right now we're just
not getting those pro we're not we're
not getting the policy nor are we
getting the programs or operations you
know brandon we had a guest on in the
last hours talking about many of these
migrants or arriving via boston places
like new york city i believe five or six
such buses filled uh this this past
weekend arriving in the new york port
authority uh and oftentimes those people
get off the bus and they can go wherever
they want they're given a slip of paper
for a return court date and all that
but where they go and how they're set up
no one's tracking them and i'm wondering
uh this one particular guest was talking
about the possibility that they have to
then pay back some of the cartels that
might have gotten them across the border
in the first place
and that heightens the danger because we
we don't know where they are
but we know where some of them are doing
someone else's bidding and it's not good
bidding
no absolutely and they do have to pay
back cartels when you look at these
individuals right now that you're seeing
coming off the bus those individuals do
not have six thousand dollars in their
pocket to give to the cartels up front
um and depending upon where you're
coming from if you're coming from china
you're paying upwards of 35 to 50 000
now i make a very good living and i
don't have that just sitting around to
give to give cartels these individuals
do not either these people are going to
indent they're going into indentured
servitude in order to pay back the
cartels and unfortunately for young
women and children that oftentimes means
the sex trade which is very dangerous
for them and that's what's very very
frustrating to all of us we want to
protect
the sanctity of life we want to ensure
that individuals
are are free to make proper choices but
when they're in when they're indebted to
the cartels they have to do everything
they can to pay them back because their
families back in their home countries
they rely upon that and if they don't
pay them back it's going to be the
families that end up paying for it um
and that's the the serious danger and
that's why we're so frustrated right now
we don't understand why the biden
administration doesn't recognize that
what they're doing is they're putting
vulnerable women and children in harm's
way with their reckless policies when
you have open border policies and what i
mean by that it's the reward it's when
we catch them and we release them that's
the reward and that's the open border
policy
when you have that all you're doing is
endangering human life and that doesn't
make sense yeah including the people who
got over the border uh thank you very
very much brendan judd
uh again we were showing you a live chat
at the border right now drone shot
that is ground zero in all of this and
it continues to be
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight